[Music]
and for katy perry those skin tight
jeans were actually leather pants split
straight down the
center you can't control everything it
all went down during the first round of
hollywood week on american idol as more
than 100 contestants headed to la to
perform for the singer and her fellow
judges lionel richie and luke bryan this
year we got a lot more raw talent and
you don't know how they're going to
evolve to ease everyone's nerves luke
started singing katie's hit song teenage
dream all right here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
and things were going fine until
[Music]
yep katie splits her skin tight red
leather pants but come on this is katy
perry we're talking about so you know
she handled it like a
some gaffer pro
i'm so sorry
all video will be collected
i think it's just the notes
[Applause]
but this isn't the first time katie's
had a wardrobe mishap on the show that's
why you have to keep watching the same
thing happened in 2018 during her first
season as a judge but this time less
impromptu singing more impromptu dancing
[Music]
it's a total deja vu moment because luke
saved the day
[Music]
oh dear god oh my god
[Music]
everything covered yup talk about
teamwork people think that this is just
for the show honestly aren't we going to
dinner after this we are going to
we
actually like each other i know that may
sound strange but we actually like each
other and like to hang i think the
greatest compliment that luke said last
night was when we walked in he said god
i'm glad to see you all he said i feel
calm now
and if you ask host ryan seacrest that
close bond has a lot to do with the
success of the show it's you know i i
credit to the judges the show has
navigated itself into a it's the same
franchise but it really is a different
show in tone and you see that with the
the kind of artists that come in the
different types of singers that come in
the styles that come in that wouldn't
have been here in its first few phases
of the show and that's why you know the
navigation of the judges i think we care
we really really care about the
contestants and we
really make
american idols like still to this day
you know what they say the judges that
help fix each other's pants
[Applause]
stay together
[Applause]
[Music]
you